one month ago dr fauci announced that he
would retire by the end of joe biden's
term as president which would have put
that somewhere around the year 2024.
yesterday fauci dramatically moved up
the timetable in a written statement he
announced
i will be stepping down from the
positions of director of the national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases
niaid and chief of the niaid laboratory
of immunoregulation
as well as the position of chief medical
advisor to president joe biden
now for the millions of americans whose
life fauci almost single-handedly
up-ended in some cases destroyed over
the past few years this announcement was
good
and welcome
and unexpected news
but much like the hiv virus that fauci
botched and bungled for decades
dr fauci
does not simply go away
his statement continued
i will be leaving these positions in
december of this year to pursue the next
chapter of my career
while i am moving on from my current
positions i am not retiring
after more than 50 years of government
service i plan to pursue the next phase
of my career while i still have so much
energy and passion for my field
now i knew fauci would never actually
voluntarily retire he loves power he
loves controlling people
and he loves seeing his own face on tv
fauci was a little bit vague about what
he's considering for the next phase of
his career i for one think that he
should become the director of the wuhan
institute of virology he's clearly on
great terms with that laboratory he's
secretly funded research there including
gain of function research and then he
lied about it when he became when it
became clear rather that gain of
function research at the wuhan lab
almost certainly caused the global
pandemic it would be the ultimate troll
and flaunting of unaccountable power for
a man who loves both and most
importantly it would probably do dr
fauci some good to get as far away from
washington dc as possible because the
only reason that he accelerated his
plans to leave the nih is because he
thinks republicans are going to win back
the congress and he knows that
republicans are pledging to make a big
show
of investigating him and he knows that
he's got four decades of incompetence
and lies and deceit to answer for i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from steve robson
who says the government seems to think
that if i lose fifty thousand dollars at
a casino and win five thousand dollars
back the next day and get comp to free
room somehow i've come out on top yes
that is the argument they're making hey
guys gas is 65 more expensive today than
when i took office but it's 20 cents
cheaper than it was last month you're
welcome
you're welcome and cnn and all the rest
of them applaud them applaud the white
house in that propaganda effort i don't
think it's fooling anybody okay but it
is tough it is tough to make your dollar
uh last these days because of inflation
because americans are hurting in their
wallets that's why it's so important to
get american home shield right now head
on over to ahs.com
knowles we could all use some peace of
mind when it comes to staying on budget
right now especially when it comes to
your home keep your budget goals in
check with american home shield they
offer a choice of three great plans to
help cover the cost to repair or replace
parts of your major home systems and
appliances both new and old if american
home shield can't repair a covered item
they will replace it from hvac systems
and plumbing to kitchen appliances their
plans help protect parts of up to 23
essential home systems and appliances
electronics coverage available for an
unlimited number of eligible items such
as smart watches flat screen tvs and
more other options include roof leak
repair and pool and spa coverage
coverage available no matter how old
your systems and appliances are plus
they're offering an exclusive 50 bucks
off to our listeners keep your home up
and running and budget on track with
american home shield right now our
listeners can take 50 bucks off their
most comprehensive plans ever ahs.com
knowles to save 50 bucks that's ahs.com
knowles for 50 bucks off any plan
american home shield be sure with the
shield service fees limitations and
exclusions apply c plan for details
voucher thinks he's going to get away
with it
maybe he will i don't know
i hope he doesn't
but republicans get squishy and then
they just move on to the next shiny
object
republicans they're going to see a
little butterfly and just get totally
distracted and lose sight of what they
were supposed to be focusing on which is
punishing dr fauci and getting getting
to the bottom of all of his incompetence
and the deceit and how he screwed up
people's lives for three years
two and a half years rand paul says he's
not going to get away with it he says
quote fouch's resignation will not
prevent a full-throated investigation
into the origins of the pandemic it will
be asked to testify under oath regarding
any discussions he participated in
concerning the lab leak
which i hope is true senator paul has
been great on the fouchy issue so far
he's grilled him and owned him with
facts and logic in the senate but we've
really got to stick to this do not let
him
sneak away fauci actually said this when
he announced a month ago that he would
be
stepping down by the end of biden's term
he actually said one of the reasons he
was doing that is because it will make
it less likely that the republicans will
investigate him i went to look back for
that clip because it was a public clip i
remember seeing it and like so many of
dr fatchi's clips it's really hard to
find on the internet right now they just
sort of disappear a lot of these clips i
i can only go back and find them on my
show
because the original source clips they
just get memory hold on the internet but
it's really important this man
destroyed people's lives
the two and a half years of the coveted
lockdowns which were completely
unnecessary which were capricious and
arbitrary which punished one group of
people conservatives and allowed another
group of people the libs to do whatever
they wanted shut down churches shut down
grandma's funeral shut down your
business but leave open the the
marijuana dispensary leave open the blm
riots that you can't go you can't go to
the funerals for your family members but
george floyd he gets four funerals okay
just completely
arbitrary wielding of power
to attack the conservatives and to
reward the libs and it was being done
because of fauci's recommendations and
he's trying to weasel out of it dr
fatchi has come out and he said he said
listen listen here i never i never in
any way suggested we should lock down
the country
there were
authorities that made different
decisions than the cdc's recommendations
for example on school closures and they
did not see higher levels of child
mortality when it comes to covet and
meanwhile the schools that did close
down we're now seeing just disastrous
levels of learning loss among poor
children children of color mental health
crisis i wonder if you would recommend
locking down schools if you had to do it
all over again
well you know again it's first of all i
didn't recommend locking anything down
you you're asking me questions you're
talking about the cdc is the public
health agency
that uses their epidemiologist and their
science-based approach to make
recommendations
i didn't recommend lagging anything down
you're lying don't stop saying that
about me okay so that's one perspective
now to give the opposite perspective
here is dr fauci
your reaction to rand paul and others
saying they're going to investigate you
if they take power
well there's there's no reason to do
that but if they want to go ahead my
records are an open book
they are talking about things that are
really bizarre john like crimes against
democracy by shutting down the
government all i have ever done and go
back and look at everything i've ever
done was to recommend
common sense good cdc recommended public
health policies that have saved millions
of lives if you want to investigate for
me for that go ahead
dr fauci
obviously recommended locking down the
country now he denies it because he
knows he's going to get in a lot of
trouble for that
so i hope if i hope the republicans
retake the house i hope they retake the
senate and i hope they just grill this
guy he's not done even
they should grill him even if he were
just going to retire and go off into the
sunset but he says he's not going to do
that he wants to continue to wield power
and influence we should not
it would be a disgrace to the republican
party if we let him do that government
bureaucrats and technocrats are coming
after us they're not going to pull back
and say okay kovid was pretty bad we
really went after those people now let's
pull back a little bit no they're
doubling down on it the dems just
authorized 87 000 new irs agents many of
whom are apparently going to be carrying
guns to go shake you down to go get
money from you there's a training video
my goodness there's a news report
showing the irs training right now you
would think that they were training not
a group of accountants you'd think they
were training the swat team
congress recently appropriated funds so
the irs is currently looking to hire
more special agents or cis nationwide
looking around starting around
60
70 000 somewhere in there
and then the advancements are you'll
move up
you know one level every year for the
first few years so
an agent that's been in the field for a
long time can top out at around 175 000
a year as well as benefits and
retirement these aren't actual police
officers they're students posing as
special agents for the irs arresting a
man who has wanted four tax evasions
who are you guys
uh what is this or the irs
you're under arrest you're going to jail
buddy
most people don't even know that the irs
has criminal investigators who use their
accounting skills and their authority as
a special irs agent to help solve tax
crimes under this scenario these
students find the owner of a landscaping
company has several vehicles that may
have been purchased from monies not
reported through his business this is
revenge of the nerds this is the real
revenge of the nerds the kid you made
fun of in school because of his pocket
protector and his little calculator well
no more mr nice accountant anymore no
get on your knees
gun drawn
we're the irs and you're going to
jailbuddy the most
important part of that news report
is this
who were they going after were they
going after the billionaire
were they going after the mafioso
the capo d2t copy were they going after
al capone no
they were going after a guy with a
landscaping business because he didn't
buy his his equipment in the right way
that's that's who that's who they were
going after in the training session
that was being broadcast on the network
news
they're they're not going after the
gazillionaires they're coming after the
middle class they are coming after you
and apparently they're armed
now when you've got to think about
ultimate questions questions of life and
death you really got to make sure you
have a will that's why you got to check
out epic will right now go to
epicwheel.com use code knowles the
left's persistent and loud attack on
truth is aimed directly at your children
the public school system mainstream kids
entertainment social platforms seemingly
all of our country's cultural
institutions have been infiltrated by
the left's not so secret agenda their
words not mine to indoctrinate your kids
with weird sex stuff and anti-religious
ideologies and anti-american views and
marxism and socialism and all the rest
of it there are a lot of ways you can
protect your kids from these not so
secret agendas you can homeschool you
can get them involved in your church but
one of the easiest and simplest ways to
protect your kids is to take five
minutes tonight write a will with epic
will you can do it it's an online
platform it costs less than your next
trip to target they can set you up with
a will in as little as five minutes
starting at just 119 bucks plus you can
save 10 percent when you go to epic will
dot com use code knowles k w l e s take
five minutes tonight write a will
ensuring that your kids will be raised
the way you intend in the event that
something happens to you epicwheel.com
use my code knowles today
speaking of economic liberty people
people trying to make us all poorer joe
biden's energy secretary jennifer granom
has some advice for people who are
really really stretched thin right now
can't afford gas can't afford the price
of regular household goods can't afford
to heat their homes she says look guys
it's really simple if you're too poor to
afford energy right now just get some
solar panels
and really you could make the same
argument we were talking about tax
breaks for adding solar panels energy
efficient windows appliances heat pumps
you know what do you say to the families
who simply can't afford this stuff in
the first place
well number one for your home yes there
are significant incentives in this bill
which is great to reduce people's energy
costs on a monthly basis so if you are
low income you can get your home
entirely weatherized through the
expansion from the bipartisan
infrastructure law significant expansion
you don't have to pay for anything if
you want uh heat pumps insulation new
windows that is covered if you are
moderate income today you can get 30
off the price of solar panels those
solar panels can be financed so you
don't have to have the big outcome
outlay at the front and when they're
financed they're financed to the in a
way that reduces your energy bill even
though you have solar panels with this
30 percent off it's a significant
incentive
it's it's really significant you can
save 30
on your solar panels right now so just
go on go buy it i don't see what the big
deal is
pay our democrat friends in the green
energy industry a bunch of money
and do it this reminds me just of pete
butterjudge
when and the gas prices were at true
record highs all-time record highs and
pete budage was asked hey what do you
say to people who can't afford to fill
their car up with gasoline he says
well why don't they just buy an electric
car
why don't look maybe they can't afford
that tesla x they don't have a hundred
hundred fifty thousand dollars lying
around but look at least you should be
able to afford the fifty thousand dollar
one what are you broke
do they hear themselves
they're headed for disaster in november
and they're telling people
let them
let them use solar the people cannot
afford to eat let them use solar let
them drive tesla
you know marie antoinette never said let
them eat cake that is
one of the worst smears
in the history of politics and marie
antoinette was a good woman and she
never said it and the line actually
dates back before marie antoinette was
ever queen of france before she was ever
alive but
these people actually are saying let
them use solar power let them drive
teslas how on earth could anyone support
these people on really really basic
stuff
hey the people can't afford gas they say
whatever who cares about that i'm saving
the world buddy i'm saving the world i'm
fighting off the sun monster who cares
if poor people are going to freeze this
winter who cares if you can't afford to
feed your kids or dr or drive to your
work but don't worry we shut down your
work
don't yeah you should have that laptop
lifestyle too bad you're working a job
that requires you to be in a place and
maybe use your hands even yeah too bad
yeah i guess you should you should go
into harvard
come on you should you should have
learned to code
and all the other issues too oh what you
don't want your you don't want your kids
to be trans in elementary school
you don't want you don't want weird
psycho left-wing teachers and guidance
counselors to tell your kid that she
needs to be pumped full of hormones and
mutilate her body to look more like a
little boy well too bad we're going to
do it anyway too bad
yeah we're going to have drag queen
story hour yeah we don't care what you
little people think that's just what
we're going to do and in the face of all
this i ask myself who on earth could
support these people
who could increasingly it's not voters
across really any demographic dems are
losing ground among all the racial
demographics they're really losing
ground among hispanics they're really
losing ground among the working class
no you know who supports these people
liz cheney that's who
liz cheney the fake republican who just
lost her congressional seat because
she's a big court jester conservative
squish
liz cheney is doubling down she's just
like fauci says i might i might be
stepping down but i'm not finished i'm
coming back i won't retire the same
thing is true of liz cheney she says
that she is now in in the coming
elections going to
campaign for certain democrats against
certain republicans especially those
republicans are election deniers
so this is obviously not the end this is
a new beginning for you you're starting
this political organization
what can you tell us what are you going
to do i'm going to be very focused on
working to ensure that we do everything
we can
not to elect election deniers and i'm
going to work
against those people i'm going to work
to support their opponents i think it
matters that much will you be getting
involved in campaigns against those
republican candidates that are
challenging
or denying the results of the election
yes including your republican colleagues
here in congress yes that phrase
election deniers that's a very specific
phrase i hadn't really heard it before a
couple of weeks ago now i'm hearing it
everywhere you heard liz cheney there
used the phrase you then heard the
journalist john carl repeat it says
denying denial you hear the deniers why
are they doing that they're the libs are
using that phrase election deniers in
the same way they they use the phrase
climate deniers which is to smear
conservatives as nazis by calling to
mind the
older and better established phrase
holocaust deniers that's what it's about
it's especially clear when it comes to
climate deniers because that's such a
bizarre phrase who denies the climate
i'm not denying the climate i'm
breathing the air i'm breathing some
oxygen a lot of nitrogen i don't deny
that there's a climate
no you are your denier and it's because
it calls to mind whether you're aware of
it or not it does conjure up these
images of holocaust deniers and so it's
it's the same accusation that the libs
make against anyone even slightly to
their right that they always do namely
that we're all nazis this wasn't just a
one-off it wasn't an accidental turn of
phrase from liz cheney or john carl abc
has been pushing this relentlessly
mark what what is your sense on
the role that she has
taken on i i think she has been look i
would say that she's unleashed but she
was pretty unleashed before the election
but i think she will be an extremely
relevant figure in her party i think
across the board i i think
she seems like she is one committed not
only to sort of take down donald trump
but to take down the sickness of her
party i mean she seems to be going more
broadly beyond january 6 at this point
she's talking about denial she's talking
about election denial january 6th denial
um you know the question is will she go
into like coveted denial or climate
denial things like that going forward
but ultimately i think she's going to
raise a ton of money i think she'll get
a ton of media attention and i think
that she her place in our politics is
solidified for the time being and
probably beyond you know next year
that guy his name is leibovitch
something leibovich he writes for the
atlantic giving you exactly the kind of
astute political analysis that you would
expect mark levovich he says oh liz
cheney she's going to be so extremely
relevant to the republican party liz
cheney hasn't been relevant in the
republican party in years she's already
completely irrelevant she lost her seat
she was overwhelmingly she was trounced
not just overwhelmingly thrown out she
was destroyed with facts and votes and
logic in wyoming wyoming is a pretty red
state okay it's a republican state she
has no relevance in her party at all and
she hasn't ever since she decided to
for all intents and purposes switch
teams and become a pr flag for nancy
pelosi so she might have some relevance
on left-wing cable news she might have
some relevance in the break room at the
atlantic she has absolutely no relevance
among the republicans and you see what
they're doing too initially we were told
initially liz cheney told us adam
kinzinger all the libs and the squishes
they said this isn't this isn't about
any issues
it's not about conservatism it's about
trump trump is a unique threat
he is the problem i'm a good republican
i respect republicans i'm a tried and
true principled conservative republican
it's just trump
and now what do we hear well but maybe
it's a little more than trump
yeah well maybe i mean i know trump's
out of office maybe maybe it's about
maybe it's some of the other house
republicans too maybe it's about it's
not even just about the 2020 election
maybe it's about the climate change
maybe maybe it's about covid are you a
covid denier maybe it's about maybe it's
about just giving the libs more power
and taking power away from conservatives
that's all it's about so if liz cheney
is going to have any relevance at all
it will be as the kind of
you know dancing monkey for the democrat
party it will be as the court jester
conservative in the kingdom of
liberalism but she will have absolutely
no
absolutely no relevance in the
republican party could you imagine i
mean someone who
goes along and actually parrots phrases
that are designed and intended
simply to smear conservatives you're
allegedly your fellow partisans
allegedly your the people who agree with
you on so many important issues to smear
them as nazis that's what this is about
this is
really really sad
stuff
and you're seeing this this
political culture now turn our own
country into basically a banana republic
i mean i think it was pretty clear when
the
biden doj the political appointee at the
biden doj made the call to use federal
law enforcement to raid
biden's predecessor and chief political
rival you saw our country being thrust
into banana republic territory
now the corporate media not only control
what they want you to know but their
agenda means the news is presented in a
very biased way
you know it i know we all know it
thankfully there's a way to get the most
important news of the day without their
super duper lib narrative that would be
morning wire
make sure you give it a listen you get
all the news of the day in 15 minutes
you'll get the dulcet tones of john
bickley of georgia howe of cabot
phillips is really fabulous i absolutely
love it so make sure you go subscribe to
morning wire today
speaking of banana republics
right down now in brazil you are seeing
a
uh
well unfortunately the sort of thing
that we probably have to look forward to
here brazil's federal police requested
authorization from the nation's federal
supreme court to formally indict
brazil's president jair bolsonaro
why do they want to indict him bolsonaro
just announced his re-election campaign
so the timing here is a little suspect
the federal police want to indict
bolsonaro who's behind the indictment by
the way is bolsonaro's political
opponent the brazilian senator omar aziz
so as bolsonaro is about to launch his
campaign
for re-election this guy comes out the
political opponent says all right we got
to arrest this guy and what was
bolsonaro's crime
this one is even more ridiculous than
the nonsense they're accusing trump of
you know the presidential records act or
whatever
the
the crime that bolsonaro is being
accused of
is spreading
misinformation about kovid
there's a law i guess again spreading
misinformation about kovid and you see
bolsonaro he spread all that
misinformation because he suggested
maybe there were some negative side
effects of the vaccines and maybe the
vaccines didn't work as well as everyone
was saying they did and maybe the masks
were really stupid and didn't do very
much of anything
and so because bolsonaro spread that
obviously true information i'm sorry i'm
sorry i must have misspoke i meant you
know that
legally classified
misinformation because of that
he could be indicted
and this would obviously throw an
impediment into his presidential
campaign we'll see how it plays that
i expect this from brazil i expect this
from latin america that's how they do
politics down in latin america
until august 8th
of this year
that is not how we do politics in
america that was not how we did politics
in america joe biden changed that
because joe biden's attorney general
merrick garland
launched a raid federal law enforcement
knocking down the door of joe biden's
chief political rival
banana republic stuff i don't mind
banana republic stuff as much when it
occurs in banana republics
i don't like it when it occurs in our
republic speaking of foreign political
leaders there is a story a little bit
saucy a little bit spicy for this show
even though we're a family show so i'm
going to try to keep it clean the prime
minister of
finland
is a
well i'll i think the technical phrase
would be super hot young woman and the
prime minister her name is
sana marin
has
created a number of tabloid scandals
because she keeps getting out getting
caught going out and partying and
dancing and staying up really late now
their videos going around of her dancing
with some guy real close real intimates
he seems to be sort of nibbling on her
uh the guy is not her husband
if if you haven't seen the video take a
listen
so all right that guy's getting real
friendly with
the prime minister of finland
all i keep thinking is could you imagine
biden doing this like if our head of
state
i wouldn't i wouldn't like that
did you imagine the two of them together
i guess you would mostly be smelling her
hair so she's there at santa marin is at
this club she's dancing then there's
another video that's been going viral of
her kind of dancing jiggling
provocatively with a bunch of
girlfriends at some house party
they're all singing along to club music
and jumping up and down and
strutting about and
there's some guys there okay you get the
idea this is the kind of thing
this is the kind of thing
that 18 year olds do
it's the kind of thing that even in your
20s you do this okay
it's not what you expect from the prime
minister of a country and i don't i
don't want to be the fun police i really
don't
but my reaction to this
some people have said good for her
you go girl yeah and
that's the kind of lib perspective
and then
you know you get the sort of apolitical
perspective of hey if she wants to do it
what's the big deal who cares you know
and then a lot of other people are just
noticing that
she's a very good-looking woman and if
she were not a good-looking woman it
probably wouldn't be as cute
people wouldn't find it as charming as
they do because of this lady my reaction
to it though is
grow up
lady
grow up i'm not really even knocking
this kind of thing when you're in your
20s when you're single when you're in
college
when you're i'm not knocking that all
right it's fun it's fun going to parties
fun dancing around i assume all the
people in those videos were had had had
a couple coca-colas all right that's
that but there's a time for every
purpose under heaven there's a time to
go clubbing and a time to refrain from
the clubbing and when you're 36 and
you're married with a kid and you're the
prime minister of a country
probably you shouldn't do that
she got in trouble too this was a little
while ago
a year or so ago at least at least eight
or nine months ago when the prime
minister lady goes out to a club on
saturday after her foreign minister had
tested positive and she was told for uh
kovid then she was told she did not need
to isolate because she was vaccinated
but then she got a text reminding her
that the vaccine
doesn't really do all that much and so
she uh she was they told her you got to
come home you got to isolate but she
didn't do that because she missed the
text because she left her phone at the
office and she was just out clubbing all
night and i just think lady grow up this
is a problem
for really the whole millennial
generation of which she and i are both
apart
which is
we don't want to grow up
we all just want to remain in perpetual
adolescence
this is why millennials use the term
adulting say wow i was adulting to i
paid my bills i was adulting
so that's unusual
i guess it is unusual these days but it
shouldn't be and you shouldn't be
boasting about how you're doing adult
things at 35 years old
you should just do them but they want to
put off everything they want to put off
getting married they want to put off
having kids when they do get married and
have kids they want to put off or just
neglect entirely the obligations that
come with that
they want to put they just don't want to
put it off and that's not good that's
not a good way to live
okay that that will fade the fun will
fade even looks will fade
i should be doing the right thing in the
meantime speaking of dating there's a
story in the wall street journal
that there's been a major change in the
dating scene
and that is that people
are moving in large numbers towards
sober dating
so what do i know i haven't dated in a
thousand years and i married my high
school sweetheart but in my mind dating
is when you go out and you know you get
some drinks or maybe if you don't drink
you go out and
you get appetizers or dinner or
something like that
but probably you know unless you unless
you have an alcohol problem or something
you're really intentionally refraining
most people i think will have a drink on
a date now that's not what's happening
according to the wall street journal and
tinder mentions of sober increased 26
from 2020 to 2021 in member bios
now it's up again another 22 percent
this year according to tinder
uh and mentions of the words beach
and picnic are also up quite a lot from
the beginning of the year suggesting
that people are meeting up for not just
going to a bar not just going to a club
not just going to a restaurant but going
out and having a
going and just having a picnic or having
a cheaper day so
the good side of this is it's probably
good if people don't drink as much if
people decide that there's more to life
than just drinking that's probably good
for people's health
it's there's nothing wrong with saving
money we're in a terrible economy right
now so if you don't want to go to some
expensive fancy restaurant you'd rather
go have a picnic that sounds charming i
actually think that sounds lovely
but i see a dark social trend lurking
beneath the surface here my first
reaction when i saw this is
i don't think the reason that people
aren't drinking on dates is fruit
necessarily for their personal health i
don't even think it's just to save money
i think it's a sign of social breakdown
and i think it's because people are
afraid
that when they if they drink too much on
a date they're going to be taken
advantage of they could be raped they
could make decisions that they come to
regret in the morning people are dating
people that they have absolutely no
connection to other than just swiping
right it's not like you're being set up
on a blind date by a friend or this is
someone you're in school with or that
you work with or that you know through
your church it's just totally random
people could be a psycho serial killer
and so people want to keep their wits
about them which is which is kind of
scary
and i that was my first instinct and i
read later down in the very same article
they quote a chicago dating coach steph
safran
who says
that people are more concerned about
safety
they're worried about facing sexual
pressure
having a date slip them a mickey in
their drink while they're not looking
and she says that not drinking helps her
clients ensure that they don't do
anything that they would regret in the
morning
so again that's good
good for people to avoid getting mickeys
slipped in their drink and avoid doing
things that they'll regret in the
morning
but this is a sign that maybe
something's not quite right with this
new way that we're dating because in the
old way of dating
you had more connections to a person
than just showing up randomly to meet
them
you had more you had
the the community was more tightly knit
and there were
more interconnected bonds between people
oh how did you meet oh because johnny
was
was jim's roommate in college and jim is
my sister sally's husband and i with
there were all of these connections so
you would be
far less likely to be victimized on a
date because the person wasn't just a
total rando wasn't just a total stranger
here could disappear the next day you
don't even know his real name that's a
sign of social breakdown yeah it's good
if people want to save some money and
take care of their health but if this is
what i think it is and what this dating
coach seems to think it is if this is a
sign that people are putting up their
guards because they're afraid of
stranger danger and even the people that
they're going on what's supposed to be a
romantic occasion with might might
attack them might abuse them might
victimize them that's not a good place
to be
as a society
speaking of love and marriage in the
baby carriage
another horrifying report also from the
wall street journal actually
the cost of raising a child has
increased
dramatically
the cost of raising a child do you know
what it is right now i'll let you
formulate a guess in your mind maybe
type it out in the comments section
before i tell you
it's over 300 000
wall street journal says that according
to the brookings institution which is a
left-wing institution sort of
center-left
their analysis finds
it can cost up to over three hundred ten
thousand six hundred five dollars to
raise a child in today's economy that
works out to an average of eighteen
thousand two hundred seventy one dollars
per year to raise a child born after
2015. this is based on 2017 data from
the us department of agriculture it
suggested for current inflation
and they they
analysis looked at other things beyond
just food because i thought man three
hundred ten thousand dollars that's a
time that is an insane amount of money
right
it's probably going to be more when i
think about the eggs that sweet little
elisa buys i think about the diapers you
just found these very fancy diapers that
reduce your risk of the baby kind of you
know
going beyond the diapers so that's good
i like that but these diapers are made
of like silk and gold i think that's the
only way to justify the expense so i
think i'll be lucky if i get off three
hundred thousand dollars a kid
that's an insane amount of money three
hundred thousand dollars a kid what's
driving the price is it gas sure is it
food uh-huh yeah but then brookings kind
of
nestles another little cost in there
housing
clothing
health care
and child care among other expenses and
there it is
there's the problem
the child care which is bizarre it's
bizarre that in our world right now
people need
virtually everyone needs two incomes
to survive as a family
but then what do you do with the kids
you get into a situation where you send
your wife to go work for some guy so the
guy can pay you guys money so that you
can pay some other woman to raise your
kids does that make sense i guess that
increases gdp because you've got all
this money moving through the economy
but it doesn't make a whole lot of sense
to me
do you know what child care costs
many of you out there probably do but
there's a cnbc analysis here
the average price of
of a year of child care
in 2019 was 9687.
in 2020 just in one year it increased to
10 174
it's the average price some in some
places more expensive places it's going
to be much more expensive even than that
and what's really scary about this over
that period of time inflation was just
1.2 percent but the increase in cost of
child care is 5
and that's not an isolated year that's
this has been going on this trend has
been going on for years
so now maybe you say okay well
sure you're talking about over ten
thousand dollars for child care now i
mean this was 2020 now it's certainly
much higher especially with buyed
inflation
let's say it's 11 000 12 000 13 000
whatever you're paying right now you say
okay that's fine but whatever you know
look that that child care allows my wife
to have a job where let's let's say she
makes fifty thousand dollars at her job
so okay that's a win right
except
are you only gonna have one child a lot
of people are for economic reasons
let's say you got two children okay now
we're talking about 20 to
25 26 000 a year
well you say okay it's not a big deal
because my wife's still making that 50
grand that i just told you about okay
except that's 50 grand before taxes
after taxes what's that 50 grand it's
gonna be closer to 25 or 30 grand
so now her entire salary goes away
you're still only dealing with two kids
what about that third you're not even at
replacement at that point the
replacement rate is 2.1 because you know
god forbid something terrible happens
but you know you look at mortality so
you for a population have a replacement
birth rate you want 2.1 kids per couple
you're not even there yet
now three kids all of a sudden it costs
more money for child care than your
wife's making it her salary and i just
picked a random number 50 grand some
people could be making less some people
could be making more that is an
unsustainable thing this is why the
campaign of blake masters who's running
for senate
in arizona right now the thing that
really turned me on to this guy
is he had a commercial where he said i
think that in america you should be able
to raise a family
on a single income i think that's
absolutely true that's so so important
and it's especially true if you're a
conservative
because conservatives believe that the
family is the basic unit of society we
always talk about family values we talk
about protecting the rights of the
family
well how can you do that if you can't
afford to have your family raise your
own kids
how can we protect family values if it's
economically extremely difficult it's
not impossible
even for people at the lower end of the
income spectrum it's not impossible but
it's really really hard
to support a family on a single income
that is a political problem and pull
yourself up by your bootstraps let
people do whatever they want bs that's
not going to fix it we need to deal with
this in a political way we know the libs
have been trying to destroy the family
for
well over 100 years
significantly more than 100 years
actually we know that
so what are we going to do
to actually to
to defend the family because this is
unsustainable
and it creates a political problem we
have a dying country
for 50 years now our country's been
dying we're not having enough babies to
replace ourselves and that
ties into all sorts of other political
problems ties into mass migration the
only reason that we have mass migration
in this country is because we don't have
enough people being born in this country
to support our gdp and our welfare state
and especially with you with all the
baby boomers retiring the economy would
collapse if we didn't flood the place
with foreigners that's why the libs all
want the foreigners to come in because
they want to upend our country and get
rid of our traditions and they think
it'll help them with the ballot box and
that's largely true though
it's a little debatable
in recent years but it's still largely
true it helps them and but the chamber
of commerce republicans allowed them to
come in because otherwise the economy
would collapse
a major problem and yet you still have
some conservatives who say well what is
the government what's the government's
business in marriage i think the
government should get out of the
marriage business government just needs
to leave us alone
the government is not going to leave you
alone that has never happened anywhere
in any state ever
the government if it has any interests
at all
is interested in marriage
because it's the fundamental political
institution
and throwing your hands up in the air is
not going to be a real solution to the
problems just going to let the libs make
things worse don't do that speaking of
raising kids and speaking of standing up
to bad government and bad culture and
just
bad ideas all around
we reported on this show a week or two
ago
that
transgender crazy ideology was not just
affecting new york and california and
san francisco in chicago it's in
tennessee even in tennessee i love this
place i fled to tennessee as an oasis of
tradition and the good life and properly
understood freedom and then i find out a
school in my own backyard harpeth hall
right here in nashville tennessee most
famous girls school in the state
probably
was going to embrace transgenderism
the most famous girls school was going
to stop being a girls school
it's going to start letting boys in
we said on this show that's a terrible
thing i think daley wire might have
broken the story
and now what do we hear this had been
signed off on by the trustees by the
administration by everybody by everybody
except the parents by everybody except
the people
now after the outcry that came after we
all talked about it
now they're walking it back the school
sends a letter to parents they say we
recognize that this philosophy elicited
strong reactions of support and
opposition beyond our expectations we
care deeply about your feedback we have
heard you based on the response from our
school community the harpethal board of
trustees is choosing to pause
the adoption of the philosophy in order
to engage a wider audience in continued
discussion
that's great because they say here right
they say look we've got a lot of support
and we got a lot of opposition but we've
got a lot of support too right so
they're trying to save face
but that's from the broader community
the state the country the world
twitter
but then when it comes down to what did
the school actually think oh we're gonna
pause this
right because those parents don't like
it
and the minute that that
the conservative movement broadly
was able to fly some media cover for
those parents to express their totally
legitimate concerns
the school pays attention very very
important republicans have a great
opportunity here the people are on our
side on the issues
in a way that i've never seen in my
whole life
and they've got to use it properly what
is the republican party doing to advance
this
they're running seven-minute ads calling
joe biden a racist
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black poor kids are just as bright
and just as talented white kids
the first
sort of
mainstream african-american
who is articulate and bright
and clean
nice looking guy you cannot go to a
7-eleven
or a dunkin donuts unless you have a
slight indian accent unlike the
african-american community with notable
exceptions the latino community is an
incredibly diverse community
with incredibly different attitudes
about different things they're going to
put you all back in chains when haiti
just quietly sunk into the caribbean or
rose up 300 feet
it wouldn't matter a whole lot the
reason i was able to stay
sequestered in my home is because
some
black woman was able to stack the
grocery shelf it's awful hard as well
to get
latinx vaccinated as well why
they're worried that they'll be
vaccinated and deported
this ad is so
stupid i can't we sometimes make fun of
this line of attack these days the
conservatives broadly we make fun of the
line of attack democrats are the real
racists no you're a racist no you're a
racist no you're a racist does anybody
really believe joe biden hates black
people
i don't i don't like joe biden at all i
think he's a big jerk
and a terrible president and not a good
guy but do you think he hates black
people
because he
he made some inaudible comments no
no it's so dumb and yet and yet
there might be something to this tactic
tactically speaking this gets to
something i said i've said for years
the worst thing you can possibly be
called in america is a racist
a bigot broadly but specifically a
racist it's the worst thing you can be
called
and so politics just always has to come
down to race and racism even things that
have absolutely nothing to do with race
the libs are pushing their stupid
education policies and their climate
their environmentalist policies on race
everything's about race
even the weird sex stuff is about race
somehow everything's got to be about no
you're a racist no you're a racist
so tactically in the short term maybe
this is a good line of attack in the
long run though we're never going to win
on this in the long run we're never
going to win on
racial identity politics that's the libs
game the libs play that game it rip it
rigs the whole
the whole system in their favor
you just think the republican party man
they they can't they can't win for
losing these guys just could clutch
defeat out of the jaws of victory
we know in a year with record inflation
and everyone all upset over over insane
identity politics and the and and
the crt and the transing of all the kids
and the mismanagement of foreign policy
and the invasion that's the word that
most americans use to describe illegal
immigration i know we're going to do
we've got a really novel strategy we're
going to call biden a racist yeah
that'll do it
we've got the member block coming up i'm
so excited for this member block i
have been waiting for this for a couple
of weeks now we will be delving in
to the seed
oil
racket
with dr kate shanahan a lot of
conservatives are really on this right
now seed oils
many people say
are making you fat and dumb and
miserable and killing you and
i am so excited to really get into the
science here kate had some great great
articles on the daily wire about it so
be sure to head on over to the member
block links in the description
we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
you